[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In a world where
virtual collaboration
and digital transformation
is increasingly important
for organizations, finding
better ways that your team can
leverage technology to
work more efficiently
is critical to success.
This is especially true
for desk-less workers,
who are out on the
floor or in the field
and not at a computer.
For these people, it can be
challenging to create solutions
that address their needs.
Luckily, Google Cloud
is here to help.
We'll show how a team
of field technicians
can leverage Google
Cloud products to boost
their productivity.
In just a few
minutes, you should
be able to walk away with
some new ideas of how
you can harness the
power of technology
to improve the way you
and your team works.
Meet Julia.
Julia manages a team of
appliance repair experts
who respond to dozens of
job requests each day.
Julia needs an easy way to
communicate with her team,
manage the job
requests and contracts,
and provide her team
with the resources they
need to do their job.
So how does she do it?
Well, in just a
couple days, Julia
has used App Sheet, Google
Cloud's no code application
development platform, to
create a simple app to help
her manage all these tasks.
She shared this
app with her team
so they can all
collaborate around it.
The first task Julia
needs to complete
is to be able to
communicate with her team.
Julia has set up a virtual
daily standup for her team
that can be joined by
selecting Daily Standup,
then clicking on Today's Event.
This opens up a Google Meet.
Julia can then discuss over
video chat the key items,
and each member of her
team can share their plan
for the action of the day.
Customers fill out new job
requests through Google Forms,
and as the requests
come in, they
will show up in the Jobs
section of Julia's app.
She can then assign them to
the different technicians,
and they can work
with the customer
to schedule and
complete the repair.
When a technician
picks up a job,
they're able to easily create
a job contract in the app.
They simply fill out
some key information,
sign it, and save it.
The app then
automatically updates
a template that was
created in Google
Docs with the
appropriate information
and sends it to Julia
and the customer.
This app links directly
to a Google Sheet,
so anytime Julia or her team
makes updates to the app,
the sheet is updated
with the new information.
This makes it easy for
Julia to manage her data
and know where
everything is stored.
As the technician
works on a repair,
they're able to access
the manuals and repair
guides associated with
that product, which
have been uploaded to the
drive and linked in the app.
This makes it easy for her team
to access the documentation
they need while on the job.
Finally, as a technician
completes a job,
they're able to update its
status with details, pictures,
and even annotations.
These types of apps aren't just
useful for appliance repair
teams.
They can be used by construction
workers, inspectors,
health care workers, public
service representatives,
and more.
Using these Google
Cloud platforms,
creating processes
such as these can
take days or weeks,
not months or years,
to create, allowing businesses
to work faster and better.
To learn more and to access
this and other app templates,
click on the link below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]